deux semaines de guerre en ukraine et la
russie poursuit sa stratégie alterné
combat et annonce une nouvelle trêve
humanitaire est censée entrer en vigueur
ce mercredi matin selon moscou la veille
elle avait permis aux civils de fuir
soumis au nord ou encore une partie de
kiev pas marioupol ou le cessez le feu
ne serait pas respectée alors que 300000
personnes attendent toujours d'être
évacués dans le même temps les chars
russes se rapproche des grandes villes
bombardées c'est le cas de kiev où l'on
retrouve notre envoyé spécial cyril
payen un bon jour cyril la capitale
ukrainienne s'est réveillé ce matin au
son des sirènes des alertes aux
bombardements
oui la nuit a été courte je peux vous
dire ici dans le centre de kiev
effectivement avec ses sirènes qui
annonce donc des bombardements
aériens tout là toute la nuit ça n'était
pas arrivé ces dernières 48 heures donc
une nuit assez courte pour les habitants
de kiev qui ont passé bien toutes les
heures du couvre-feu dans leur abri dans
le métro ou dans des dans des caves donc
là au moment où l'on parle effectivement
c'est un nouveau jour d'annonce par
moscou d'une trêve humanitaire de
l'installation de corridors humanitaires
pour évacuer pour que les civils
d'ukrainiens puisse y évacuer les villes
et puis de cessez-le-feu en ce qui
concerne le front du nord-ouest où nous
étions toute la journée d'hier
c'est-à-dire la région dire pin et bien
je peux vous dire que le cessez-le-feu
était réellement qu'un effet d'annoncé
puisque il y a eu pendant des heures des
tirs d'artillerie des tirs de mortiers
des bombardements sur cette ville
satellitaire eu extrêmement résidentiel
où vivent des dizaines de milliers
d'ukrainiens qui se trouve à moins de 15
20 km du centre ville de kef et au
nord-ouest de la capitale donc il y
avait effectivement un corridor
humanitaire de fait mais surtout des
populations terrifié épuisé à bout de
force qui tentaient de fuir ces zones
qui sont pilonnée par l'artillerie russe
et selon les informations de nos
contacts militaires d'ukrainiens sur
place ce matin que nous avons pu avoir
par téléphone et bien les assauts
continue au moment où je vous parle et
surtout surtout les forces terrestres us
s'approche dangereusement peu ce qu
elles ne sont plus qu'à quatre ou cinq
km2 du dernier pont qui lui perd qui
permet d'avoir accès à kiev donc voilà
la réalité sur le terrain après deux
semaines de l'offensive russe donc c'est
vrai qu'ici on prend avec beaucoup de
scepticisme et pour ne pas dire
d'agacement et d'énervement de colère
les annonces quotidiennes maintenant de
cessez-le-feu des séquences du corridor
humanitaire
proposée par moscou cyrille est ce que
pour les ukrainiens tout cela on
ressemble à des prémices d'un siège de
kiev à l'avenir
à écouter à en juger par la violence de
l'offensive hier aux portes de kef
encore une fois je rappelle que c'est
l'axé nord du nord et du nord ouest qui
va donc privé maintenant de fait à la
plupart des accès ou des sorties de la
capitale ukrainienne on peut penser que
cette avancée est inexorable selon le
renseignement militaire américain a
nommément la cia cette nuit il y a eu
cette annonce qui glace un peu ici la
population d'une tentative d'assaut sur
kiev dans les 1 et 2 jours on sait que
les services militaires de renseignement
militaires américains sont en général
extrêmement bien informés ils se sont
rarement trompé sur le fond de l'aso
depuis le début de cette offensive
souvent par contre sur le le calendrier
alors ici on croit plus à une offensive
ou un encerclement un siège de kiev qui
pourrait intervenir ce week-end ou en
début de semaine prochaine mais en tout
cas les nouvelles évidemment et
dernières nouvelles ce matin en
provenance de kiev et bien ne sont pas
très bonnes